coffee on a Tuesday and vlog 43 dad
minimalism is everywhere it's a style in
which the simplest and fewest elements
are used to create the maximum effect
and you can find minimalism in almost
every art form or kind of media in the
visual arts in music and literature you
can find it in architecture and
expensive food but most importantly I
think for the current age you see it as
defining trends in advertising and
design the influence here is in good
part Japanese where Zen Buddhist
concepts of simplicity inform living
spaces and ways of life and not only for
its aesthetics but also as a moral
imperative to respect the quintessence
of thing no filmmaker for example did a
better job of capturing this then yeah
so heroes whose films you should watch
immediately after this videos over
camera always plays low to the ground
Azusa films have a two dimensional
quality exhibiting what is essentially
an organization of geometric shapes and
never forget the film frame itself is a
rectangle this for me is the key of
minimalism it's a movement of organized
geometry the relationships of shapes
inside what is essentially just a bunch
of rectangles the TV screen the computer
screen the film frame the YouTube player
the billboard the street sign or the
page a more recent influence is the
Dutch dish style movement or neoplastic
as P at Mondrian whose paintings you
will most certainly recognize said it is
possible that through horizontal and
vertical lines constructed with
awareness but not with calculation led
by high intuition and brought to harmony
and rhythm that these basic forms of
beauty supplemented if necessary by
other direct lines or curves can become
a work of art as strong as it is true
and it's true the geometrical
organization is one of intuition
influenced perhaps by symmetry and
weight in photography by the rule of
thirds
but finally achieved by a feeling this
feels right comfortable balance take my
end screen for example I must have spent
an hour making minut millimetre changes
to the elements you see here which when
pared down look like this three
rectangles in a circle
inside a larger rectangle trying to
achieve a kind of harmony between the
distances in empty blue space maybe it
was an hour wasted or maybe we are more
attracted to pieces of design that work
in a minimalist sense maybe in the full
appraisal that you take of my work the
end screen design the framing the text
the pictures reinforce or intensify the
reaction you have to the content the
rise of minimalism is symptomatic of a
chaotic culture bombarded with
information the organizational impulse
is amplified and were drawn to messages
or products that help us to assemble
disparate data into a coherent whole so
instead of this we want this and instead
of these we use this life is marked with
contradictory but balancing trends
tendencies that aim in their way to
harmonize the confusion of modernity
minimalism is a reminder and a welcome
one that in a fog of appointments and
Facebook notifications and different
types of shampoo and homework and real
work that you can breathe
right